let me show you how to make some easy
garlic steak bites put it on anything
it's so good I was lost for words get
one or two Riv eyeses or strip steaks
why am I yelling I don't know Cube that
up put it in a bowl add some olive oil
then we're going to add some seasoning
on top and gently give that a mix to a
medium H pan add some butter add some
oil then we're going to add our steak
down let that cook for 1 to 2 minutes
each side then we're going to remove
that almost make a chimery by adding
garlic some onions some Habaneros some
cilantro some parsely add some red wine
vinegar season it up then we're going to
add some lime juice kill the heat
welcome to steak back to the party let
it me a little bit and that is it this
is so good so easy portion control too
put it on anything I ain't your daddy
you got to try this one so make sure you
save this one for later but first